hi my name is Joshua Grasso I'm a
musical theater major here in the School
of Drama I'm in Pernell and the lobby
and I'm getting ready just to basically
start my my whole day of classes and
rehearsals tonight for The Full Monty
it's it's a musical filled with a lot of
heart
definitely hilarious but filled with a
lot of heart and the season was
announced for the show last year towards
like the end of last year so we
auditioned during the summer we prepared
or expected to prepare we've just come
in and from 6:30 to 10:30 we have
rehearsals Saturdays we do from 10:00 to
4:30 and then once Tech Week starts you
know we do our like 10 out of 12 which
basically means like we were here the
entire day you know we wouldn't be able
to do what we want to do or we wouldn't
be able to accomplish the things that we
have if it weren't for people to
willingly your honor you know give their
give their support to us I mean I
wouldn't be able I wouldn't be here if
it wasn't for those type of events or if
it wasn't for those people that were
generous enough to you know lend their
support like I am most firm believer
that and you can't do it yourself
you just can't you're always somehow
whether you know it or not standing on
the shoulders of people that are willing
to pick you up you know or to hold you
there so some days when you're like
should I go to class today's like yeah
you're going to class because you know
do you definitely go to class a because
it's just it's a very small it's not
even a price to pay
it's like a privilege but it pays off in
the end whether it was like successful
you know run or not you grow though you
gotta believe that you grow somehow